jordon Rodrigue covers the Panthers for
the Charlotte Observer the most recent
article inside the Panthers decision to
shut down quarterback Cam Newton and the
inevitable questions that come next
Jordan thanks for joining us who made
this decision on cam do I shut it down
hey thanks for having me big fan of the
show yeah so it was it was a collective
decision on Tuesday night Ron Rivera
head coach met with GM Marty her knee
that was owner David Tepper they all had
a real honest conversation about what
what the short-term best decision was
and then they they kind of informed cam
of his of their decision on Wednesday
morning and apparently you know he
accepted it pretty well which you know
that that's a first for him as well and
in his career to kind of go ahead with
this decision he never wants to come off
the field and and didn't actually in
week 16 or we 17 against Tampa Bay in
2016 when he was playing through the
injury so this this is a unprecedented
thing for him in his career do we know
what the injury is does he know what the
injury is well we were told when the
team announced that he had surgery we
were told and first of all he has he
injured the he injured his shoulder in
week 14 of the 2016 season didn't have
surgery and so that March so the team
announced the surgery and it was a
partially torn rotator cuff but at this
point I think what he and the medical
staff seems to be or at least publicly
seem to be struggling with is the rehab
and recovery process and why there are
still so many problems so that obviously
is concerning when apparently according
to Cam Newton they have tried treatment
after treatment after treatment kind of
gone deep into the scientific archives
of what to do and how to recover from
this and cam says you know he thinks
it's just time that he needs and you
know he's never really had it even was
late on the surgery so now he kind of
has that time and this is what that
decision is yeah and I wonder if you
have to look at Andrew Luck because you
know they they missed by a year that
that he was gonna be coming back
and you know shoulder surgery is an
inexact science and the fact that he was
coming back and Andrew Luck it took him
even longer made me wonder
I mean cam says he's Superman and I
thought well maybe he really is but I
also look at that hit that he took from
TJ watt in the Steelers game that's why
I don't know if if there is more damage
in there but just I've never heard an
athlete really tell you in full I don't
know what's going on but I've tried
everything and he was so despondent that
that's when I thought man you gotta shut
him down for his own good cuz he doesn't
even know what's wrong with him what did
you take from that press conference when
cam was talking about the shoulder yeah
you know Dan that was pretty remarkable
because like you I had never heard an
athlete open up that much about what was
going on or what the lack of knowledge
about what was going on and I thought it
was really important first of all it
seems like a little bit of a cry for
help without coming out and saying I
need help with this and I think that
that's really important because when you
when you see him without hope mentally
physically you're not getting answers
then then that's something that is a
huge concern and the team has to then
step up and make sure they're taking
care of their franchise quarterback and
so I think that that moving forward not
only are our answers needed but time is
needed as well I think that he needs to
be given the time that it takes for not
only him to come back and play healthily
but also to to kind of make sure he gets
his mind right and also you know you
have to consider too he's been throwing
around this pain I mean you kind of see
it on some of the heaves and and the
tosses he's been throwing around the
shoulder almost because it's been
causing him pain and so he needs to make
sure that he gets not only his mind
right his shoulder right but also you
know keeps those mechanics intact as
well I'm also wondering about this
Jordan and that is the draft coming up
do they start to look for his successor
and what's this mean for Ron Rivera
these final two games is he coaching for
his job in these final two games in your
opinion well my take is that he's not
Ron is not necessarily coaching for his
job I think the decisions he makes
including this one about Cam Newton that
there is a huge stake in his due
you're making those decisions and I
think that that's a reasonable way for
an owner to look for a team owner to
look at that in terms of the draft you
know Marty her knee made it clear when
he came back that they have to start
looking for maybe what's next and a guy
who maybe they can develop as a solid
backup now I think that this expedites
that process a little bit because you
need a a higher premium backup
quarterback you need kind of a guy who
could just in case step in or if they
don't even know necessarily what the
recovery time is for him you need a guy
who could who could play right away and
then of course that brings up a whole
new conversation when cam does come back
so it's a really delicate situation
they're dealing with now I would not be
surprised if they draft a quarterback
who they really would like to develop
and to eventually eventually taking over
but the problem is they don't have
answers for the middle of that they
don't have answers for the contingency
plan for the eventually and I know they
want Cam Newton to finish his career on
his terms
but all the in-between they don't have
an answer for it yet what's the local
reaction to this season well it's been
emotional and people have been really
surprised I think locally I think people
really say see the caliber of talent on
offense they see north turner come in
and the offense you know for the most
part has not really been the issue other
than when Cam Newton's shoulder really
started to kind of take a turn for the
worse and the offensive line got pretty
banged up but they see the caliber of
talent on defense and they see Ron
Rivera at the defensive minded head
coach and I think there were really high
expectations especially after that
Baltimore win that Cincinnati went and
that Philadelphia comeback when I think
people really had a lot higher
expectations and there seems to be a
little bit of shock throughout the
locker room right now because these guys
really expected those things of
themselves as well and they just they've
kind of been searching for answers all
season so I guess it is fitting that the
Cam Newton the guy who makes this team
go is also searching for answers
great stuff Jordan we appreciate your
time good luck the rest of the season
thanks guys appreciate you that's Jordan
Rodrigue
who covers Carolina Panthers Charlotte
Observer forum or Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]